hello everyone this next game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber and
actually it's been suggested to me a
couple of times so I decided to do a
video on it but before before I show
this game I do have a very cool
announcement to make those of you who've
seen my yesterday's video that video of
Gary Kasparov playing is my
brother-in-law Goran Martic well
Kasparov saw that video and he tweeted
on his Twitter account nice he said nice
and he said at one point in the video
I say how Kasparov misses a quicker win
at some point he had the move before and
this completely destroys black but then
he commented on this as well saying that
before is a good move but you should
never open you open up your King while
playing in a simultaneous exhibition
especially in a winning position so yeah
that was very cool I really enjoyed that
so okay that being said let's get back
to this game the game is played between
Magnus Carlsen and French Grandmaster
Lawrence resume and presently was a
cross in second during his World
Championship match against Anand in 2013
so this game I don't really think there
is an exact date when this game was
played but during the training period
for the match and in this game Carson
has the white pieces I think it's like a
two-minute game it's a it's a pretty
famous video on YouTube the video is
called too weak to slow you'll learn why
soon enough and it's I am pretty sure
all of you have seen it if you haven't I
will put a link in the description below
so you can check out this game with the
original footage so okay let's see the
game Carlson has the white pieces and he
plays efore we have e 6 the French
defense V 4 and now Knight to f6 the
Mediterranean defense like a variation
of the French but now Carlsen plays
Bishop to g5 and he transposes into the
trombone ski attack
we have h6 Knight captures and if Bishop
captures on f6 Queen captures on f6 and
c3 ending more protection to the d4 pawn
v6 and of course and goes night - D -
and here person a has a couple of good
options he can play Bishop e7 Knight to
c6 is fine
'if I've immediately going for the
center is fine but as this is a speed
game I'm pretty sure it's a two-minute
game he plays g5 and this this isn't
that great for black but sharp
variations are you know perfectly
allowed in a two-minute game Bishop to
d3 by Carlsen Bishop to g7 Knight to e2
a cousin is preparing to castle and also
to push f4 at some point Knight to c6
developing across in castles we have
Bishop to d7 and Carson plays f4 now and
he refers to a things for a couple of
seconds and he plays a castles Queen
side and at this point
Carson played be five and he said his
famous words too weak too slow
probably commenting on the fact that
queenside castle wasn't really the way
to go that fresney should have played
something like f G captures on f4 and
not allowing Carlsen to create such a
strong center but okay after F for
frettin a played a queenside castle and
we have E 5 the too weak to slow move
Queen to e7 costing place in characters
on b6 we have Queen captures on d6 and
the Knight to e4 centralizing the knight
would attempt on the Queen resonate
plays Queen to e7 and here it's a pretty
pretty nice position for Carlsen he has
a couple of good options here something
like Queen to b3 followed by the threat
of the night to c5 to really go for that
b7 pawn or instead maybe b4 and creating
a pawn storm on the Queen side but
instead after Queen e7 Carlsen played
night the c5 and this is actually a
blunder and even before present a played
the move that refutes this blunder
Carlsen actually suggested it to him
Carlson says and maybe you can take on
d4 and this is this is exactly what
presently does he plays Knight captures
on d4 saying to Carlsen always go carson
plays Knight captures on these
now the problem is you can't capture the
night with C captors on d4 I mean you
can if you play something like Nike
after Sunday for ten Queen captures on
c7 the knight is pinned you just lost
the pawn and after Knight capture some
before if you play C characters on d4
then Bishop captures on d4 with Czech
Knight captures Bishop on d4 and now
Queen captures on c5 pinning the night
the thread is Queen captures night with
Czech and after Carlson with defenders
probably Bishop e2 so now the Queen is
guarding the knight on d4 simply Bishop
- eh now the rook is also attacking the
knight with the Queen and after
something like rook to see one simply
Queen captures Queen captures rook
captures and all as well it's you know
same color Bishop to end game with two
rooks and frettin a is up a pawn so this
would be excellent
probably even winning so after this
night capture Sundy for Carlsen played
Knight captures on d7 and you know it's
quite an interesting game since it's a
since its speed chess Knight captures an
e2 which checked by first name Queen
captures I need to and rook characters
on d7 and here calls and pushes f5 and
it's not that this f5 really is some
sort of a threat first in he played rook
H to DA but he can just as well capture
this point with the e captures on f5
there really is no danger of Bishop
captures an f5 pinning the rook because
the bishop has to protect the Queen on e
- oh okay after f5 we had
rook H to d8 rook a to d1 Carlson plays
this saying to person a I'm gonna trick
you always or something in the lines of
that I couldn't really understand
everything they said kink the b8 for
some future nasty discovered checks from
Carlsen after the bishop comes to e 4f
captures on e6 and here Carlson says to
present it before fascinate plays the
move Queen to East Queen to e6 come on
but firstly plays F captures on e6 since
Carlson is down a pawn queen captures on
e6 would result in Queen captures and
after F captures something like Bishop
do we do actually
rooks and after the rooks are exchanged
frisina is upon up but this is an
opposite Bishop endgame this would be
easily drawn by Carlson so after F
characters on e6f characters on e6 was
played now Bishop to g4 a6 making some
breathing room for the king
g3 making room for the King on g2 Queen
Queen to c5 would check at King g2 and
now Queen to e5 Carlson asks a resume
you think this is great
we have rope characters on d7 Road
capture 77 and rook to e1 here Carlsen
asks for SNA you want to play h5 is that
what you want to play but it isn't what
the president wants to play after some
thinking he plays rook to d6 if you play
the what cost and suggested a move h5
it's it's not bad for black but he can't
really hope for any big advantage after
Bishop f3 an exchange of Queens and
after something like g4 since this h5
point is hanging after g4 rook to d1 and
again Carlson would would have no
problem drawing this game so after rook
to e1 rook to d6 was played and now
Bishop to f3 Carlson is down upon but he
offers the exchange of Queens Queen
captures any two saying you want to
exchange Queens after all rook captures
only two and b5 now and this is an
opposite color Bishop endgame with one
rook on each side that's you know not
easy to convert this advantage Bishop to
g4 now attacking the pawn pawn to e5 we
have Bishop to f3 King to a7 I came to
h3 now both players are trying to
improve the position of their King King
b6 King G for now a 5f resin is trying
to pull those pawns on the Queen side
Bishop to b4 b4 now see captures a
captures rook to c2 and now c5 as rook
to c2 does pressure this c6 square so
drew can't
move from from d6 so c5 we have b3
stopping c4 r up to d4 pinning the
bishop but again cousin plays Kim to e5
knock all sense position cousin the
position of Carlson's king is excellent
and again calls and says the words too
weak too slow saying that you allowed my
King into the position this is this is
much better for me even though I'm a
pawn down we have C for now B captures
on c4 and King to c5 blocking the pawn
and preparing to capture it cause some
places Bishop to b5 saying the words
come on come on
we have efore now now resonate gives
back up on so he can capture on c4 cross
and plays Bishop captures on e4
we have rook captures on c4 and here if
Carlson accepts the rook it's a draw but
here a Carlson says something in the
lines of you want to draw no draw and
then something I couldn't understand
what
but now Carlson got his pawn back and
Carlson doesn't want to draw anymore
across and goes a rock to e2 we have
looked the c3 now King to g6 and the
bishop to d4 as you can't really guard
this h6 point if you play something like
Bishop to f8 rough to have to again you
have to move the bishop then the king
will grab the hh6 pawn structure King to
g6 Bishop to d4 and now Carson doesn't
immediately capture the h6 pawn and this
is this is quite a decision you know
since I'm sure they both had a couple of
seconds on the clock he doesn't capture
the h6 pawn but first he plays Bishop to
c2 he improves the position not allowing
the rook to infiltrate in the position
and not allowing any b3 ideas for
resonator simple simplify the position
Bishop to e3 now Bishop to b3 now this
Bishop is also guarded by the pawn the
point is guarded by the bishop very nice
and now the King will be free to capture
the h6 pawn king d4 Crossing captures
King captures on h6 we have keen to d3
and here calls and says ah you're going
to take my rook
and place the rook to g2 and it also it
almost seems like Carson will lose that
rook we have King to e4 King to h5 by
Carlsen and now King to f3 and it seems
like the rook is almost trapped the only
move that the this rook can move to is
b2 and after this rook moves to be to it
it's probably gonna be a draw but what
presen a missed when he played King to
f3 and Carson immediately starts as
spots this is the move Bishop to d5 and
this is checkmate so a beautiful
checkmate in a beautiful speed game you
know in an opposite bit of color and
game this this is beautiful and Carlsen
asks him what do you want to play and
they both start laughing like like
madman so as you see the rook is
guarding f2 and e2 the bishop is
guarding the five point is guarding f4
King is guarding g4 Bishop is guarding
the rook here so the King has nowhere to
go
so a very nice checkmate and you know I
decided it was worth to do a short
analysis of this I will say famous game
since this is one of the most famous
videos on YouTube regarding you know
call some playing speed chess so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and you know if you haven't seen the
video where my brother-in-law plays
against Gary cause part of himself do
check it out it's you know right here
where the video shows up I would like to
thank em at Sun ski and Linda Taylor for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here one
of them will be the one I was talking
about thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon